so I've been talking about
focusing
as though it were the only valuable kind
of attention but actually mind wandering
which is the enemy of focusing the term
they use in in brain Sciences they are
anti-correlated if your mind is
wandering by definition you're not
focusing in vice versa mind wandering is
absolutely essential for Creative
insight
the creative process demands that first
of all you gather information you focus
on the problem
you really concentrate and then you let
go
the annals of science are and
Mathematics are full of people who came
up with Incredible Solutions when
they're just daydreaming in the shower
getting on a bus walking your dog
and that's because during mind wandering
we're able to make connections between
remote elements in a new way that has
value that's the definition of creative
act of course if you're going to execute
if you're going to put the idea
to use
then you have to go back into Focus but
mind wandering is extremely extremely
valuable
there's another level at which attention
operates this has to do with leadership
I I argue that leaders need three kinds
of focus to be really effective the
first is an inner Focus let me tell you
about a
case that's actually from the annals of
Neurology there was a corporate lawyer
who unfortunately had a small prefrontal
brain tumor
it was discovered early operated on
successfully after the surgery though it
was a very puzzling picture because he
was absolutely as
smart as he had been before very high IQ
no problem with the tension or memory
but he couldn't do his job anymore he
couldn't do any job he in fact he ended
up out of work his wife left him he lost
his home he's living in his brother's
spare bedroom and in despair he went to
see a famous neurologist named Antonio
dimacio demacio specializes in the
circuitry between the prefrontal area
which is where we consciously pay
attention to what matters now where we
make decisions where we learn and the
emotional centers in the midbrain
particularly the amygdala which is our
radar for radar for danger it triggers
our strong emotions they had cut the
connection between the prefrontal area
and emotional centers
and damashi at first was puzzled he he
realized that this fellow on every uh
neurological test was perfectly fine
but he something was wrong and then he
got a clue he asked the lawyer when
should we have our next appointment and
he realized the lawyer could give him
the rational pros and cons of every hour
for the next two weeks but he didn't
know which is best and DiMaggio says
when we're making a decision any
decision when to have the next
appointment should I leave my job for
another one what strategy should we
follow going into the future who should
I marry this fellow compared to all the
other fellows I made those are decisions
that require we draw on our entire life
experience and the circuitry that
collects that life experience is very
base brain it's very ancient in the
brain
and it has no direct connection to the
part of the brain that thinks in words
it has very rich connectivity to the
gastrointestinal tract to the gut so we
get a gut feeling feels right doesn't
feel right dimashio calls them somatic
markers it's a language of the body and
the ability to tune into this is
extremely important because this is
valuable data too they did a study of
California entrepreneurs and asked them
how do you make your decisions these are
people who built a business from nothing
to hundreds of millions or billions of
dollars and they more or less said the
same strategy I'm a voracious gatherer
of information I want to see the numbers
but if it doesn't feel right I won't go
ahead with the deal
they're tuning into the gut feelings I
know someone
I grew up in a the farm region of
California the Central Valley and my
high school had a rival High School in
the next town and I met a someone who
went to that other high school he would
he almost he was not a good student he
almost failed he didn't graduate came
close to not graduating high school he
went to a two-year college at Community
College as we call them
found his way into film which he loved
and got into a film School in film
School his student project caught the
eye of a director
who asked him to become an assistant
and he did so well at that that the
director arranged for him to direct his
own film someone else's script he did so
well at that they let him direct a
script that he had written
and that film did surprisingly well so
the studio that financed that film said
if you want to do another one we will
back you and he however hated the way
the studio edited the film he felt he
was a creative artist and they had
butchered his art
he said I'm going to do the film on my
own I'm going to finance it myself this
was everyone in the film business that
he knew said this is a huge mistake
you shouldn't do this but he went ahead
and he ran out of money
to had to go to 11 Banks before he could
get a loan he finished managed to finish
the film you may have seen the film it's
called Star Wars
so George Lucas made a decision on the
basis of his gut it didn't feel right to
let the studio mangle his next film he
it was his integrity and this inner
sense is
ethical it's an ethical rudder you know
it answers the question is what I'm
about to do in keeping with my sense of
meaning values purpose and ethics
that's not a question that we answer
first in words we answer first and what
feels right and doesn't feel right then
we put it into words and every leader
today needs a strong ethical Rudder so
I'd say an inner
awareness inner focus is essential